hey everyone this is kevin from the
chess website calm today I'm going to be
going over Game seven from the 2013
World Chess Championships between an on
and magnus carlsen an on so far has been
struggling the past two games he's lost
Magnus Carlsen and we're halfway through
the tournament so 12 games in this
series Magnus Carlsen with a two-point
advantage having won the last two games
definitely is in the driver's seat to go
ahead and become the new world champion
for chess so definitely exciting this
game going into seven we kind of switch
it so Magnus Carlsen started in Game one
with the white pieces and then we
flip-flopped going through the back six
anons actually gonna be starting with
the white pieces and then again will
flip-flop back and forth between who
plays white and black so anons gonna be
playing the white pieces which he
previously played in Game six and much
like Game six he decides to go for the
Rui Lopez with the Berlin defense that
Magnus Carlsen is playing which is
extremely odd to me
you know if I play chess and I've played
against the Berlin defense twice and I
almost lost the first time and the last
game I lost to I may typically want to
try to try something new a non decided
that he would just keep going I guess he
found a particularly that he liked but
definitely wanted to try the Berlin
defense one more time game definitely
had a much different look and feel to
the last game that we saw after you know
this d3 which is what a non played in
the last game but we see the bishop
coming out here very similar getting the
dark square bishop out so you know later
the pawn could come here to d6 if you
wanted to but black can kind of control
this long diagonal and then this light
square Bishop you know if it came back
here to a4 or even back here to b3 can
control this long diagonal as well but
in the game we just see the exchange
variation which I was not expecting to
see but definitely good to see a
different opening in the right Lopez so
now after the pawn takes now things are
much different than before so we see
Knight to d2 which again you could
easily see Knight to c3
here this is definitely common so Knight
to Knight to d2 is definitely one of
those that you know I'm sure and on has
been looking at for a long time there's
only a few variations that he can really
expect to the Berlin defense and
considering he kind of is setting the
pace with taking the night here on c6
with the exchange you can pretty much
assume that he's been preparing this
knight to d2 and then after the bishop
comes down playing after the pawn and
after the bishop pushes back playing
this knight to f1 now personally I think
that the knight f1 is kind of odd
dancing the night back over to the first
rank just to bring it here to g3 seems a
little bit passive from white but you
know that that's okay I'm sure he found
the line that he liked that would work
well against Magnus Carlsen so Magnus
Carlsen now decides to bring his knight
back here to d7 few other options that
he had you know if we're kind of looking
at it Magnus Carlsen has developed all
his pieces his sect his Queens so he
could bring his queen out to these six
he could bring it out to Queen to e7
both of these makes things he could go
and castle on the Kings side also a lot
of times if you have double pawns here
on you know c7 and c6 you castle on the
Queen side because you immediately have
that rook open for the semi-open file
here on the D file so definitely one
option he could go decides to go ahead
and bring his knight back here to d7 and
then the Knights gonna come here to g3
so this Knight has you know an on is
pretty much spent the last three moves
bringing this night over here to g3
attacking this bishop basically saying
hey I want to trade off my Knights for
your bishop and Magnus Carlsen just says
okay that's fine I'll just go ahead and
trade right away so I would see the
Queen come up here and then we see the
pawn push forward to g6 and this is
actually important move a lot of times
when you plays chess you have two things
that you're trying to do the first thing
is you try to develop a plan and you try
to execute that plan whether that plan
is you know I want to get to an outpost
I just want to dominate that or I want
to attack my opponents Kings side or hey
there's a small weakness he has double
isolated pawns that I want to attack on
the C file whatever that may be you have
a plan you try to execute that plan you
try to have all your pieces coordinated
to do that a lot of times your plan may
just be hey I want to limit the squares
my
poni can go to and really just choke
pretty much anything that he can do as
you can imagine magnus carlsen is
feeling good in this tournament he
doesn't have to do anything except tie
the rest of the games he could even drop
a game if he wanted to and he would go
on to be you know the world champion
that's really ultimately what he wants
to do so a lot of what I think Magnus
Carlsen is playing for is a solid
defense that he can easily just play to
really cut all the potential places that
an on can go to that could pose some
threats and so g6 does exactly that
anon wants to bring the knight here to
f5 it really caused a lot of problems
for Magnus cross since he just plays
this g6 doesn't want to fianchetto his
bishop over here more than I could just
wants to castle on the Queen side now
but this just kind of stops a lot of the
the pressure that this Knight you know
on g3 is posing you know it can no
longer come to h5 as well you know it's
kind of attacking that bishop so all of
a sudden ons moved his knight over here
to g3 took three moves to get here and
now it really can't do anything at all
so now the bishop is gonna come to e3
again completing development you always
want to get all your pieces involved
castle get your rooks connected and
figure out you know where you want to go
same thing for Magnus Carlsen plays
Queen to e7 getting ready to castle both
sides decide to go ahead and castle and
then Knight here to e2 so this again
this Knights just moving all over the
board it's not real clear what you know
an on once or even needs to do here it's
just really hard to attack this defense
from Magnus Carlsen you know again the
Berlin defense is known for being very
hard to attack but in this particular
case there there's no real clear path
forward Magnus Carlsen just brings his
rook over you know supporting the center
of the board you always want to dominate
or you know defend the center of the
board as much as possible the King's
gonna come over to be one against a
Foursquare you know protecting and
making sure something can't just sneak
past here on a2 and then start to attack
and then we see b6 you know interesting
move later you know looking to you know
bring his knight here to c5 for a nice
little outpost allowing his King to get
more involved into the action if you
- so a nice little move from him anon
decides to go ahead and you know push
forward on the kingside he does have the
majority of his pieces on the kingside
it's gonna be very difficult to move all
of his pieces over to the Queen side and
so he starts to push forward on the on
the King side which makes sense that's
really the only option to attack then we
see the King come here to b7 again nice
little place for the king especially
since his opponent doesn't have a light
square bishop it's gonna be really tough
for you know this King on b7 to come
under attack so the pawn pushes forward
and then Magnus Carlsen just decides to
go ahead and trade pieces off here on
III again as you're playing for a draw
especially as we have you know this game
right here with no real side having an
advantage if you could just trade off
all your pieces it's gonna be pretty
much a draw especially at this high
level play so again I think that's kind
of what Magnus Carlsen is going for
what's interesting in this game is with
a non having only six games left to win
- that he's just playing just to kind of
trade off pieces and kind of get to the
endgame so from here Magnus Carlsen
plays Knights here to c5 not only
developing one of his his ninth - a
better Square but kind of also opening
up this semi open square for you know
his rook here on D so it's kind of a
double move nice little square for
Magnus Carlsen with this Knight there
after the pawn takes so we're gonna have
the pawn recapture pawn here to d3
it's just kind of a waiting move can
always push forward with Knight to f4
which has you know another defender
right there but again it's not doing too
much for a non magnus carlsen pushing
forward on a5 recognizing he can't push
on the King side but he doesn't really
have a strong attack as well you know
again he just doesn't have that the
pieces to kind of break through this
this attack both sides are really just
gonna have a hard time doing anything
nan decides to play a rook over here to
h7 you always want to have your rooks on
your opponent's seventh ring they can
start to do a lot of damage but usually
they start to do damage when your
opponent's Queens off the board if they
have the Queen it's a little harder just
because they can really just control
that entire seventh rank which is with
their Queen itself so we have the rook
swing over here to h8 anon decides to go
ahead and exchange
off all the rooks and so we after the
Queen here we have the palm push forward
but then there's just going to be an
exchange right here and then the pawn
recaptures and then the Queen captures
and so anon is pretty much gave up all
of his attacking pieces so it's very
unclear how to attack from here we now
see magnus carlsen push forward with f5
after the pawn takes Magnus Carlsen can
retake be a huge mistake here you
obviously don't want to mess something
up or you know you take with your queen
you know after the the Queen takes and
the pawn takes and I can come here it's
d4 actually win a pawn and then there's
gonna be a passed pawn here on the G
file White would actually have a pretty
easy win going at the board here and
actually winning the game here so again
it's the small things in chess but you
know Magnus Carlsen isn't gonna make
that mistake decides you know capture
with the pawn and then from here there's
just no real way for anyone to do
anything both sides are completely equal
there's no way for anyone to really get
an advantage here we do see that the
King get more centralized and then we
see the knight here to to g5 you know
attacking the Queen here there's no
great square for the Queen so an on just
decides you know what I'm not gonna try
to get too creative just decides to come
back
Magnus Carlsen has no problem just
repeating moves here and so we see just
the you know this twofold repetition
here coming back and then both players
decide to draw after 30 to move so again
I think this for Magnus Carlsen is one
of the the best things that he could
have imagined he sees Anand in the
desperate situation and he plays the Rye
Lopez Berlin defense something the
Magnus Carlsen has done really great
about Anana again I think he he just
isn't quite ready for Bank Miss Carlson
he doesn't seem to be playing this the
normal anon that's been such a great
player in the in the 90s and 2000's I
think his playing style just isn't
working in this tournament
I think Magnus Carlsen may even win
another game or - I just don't see
there's any way to stop Magnus Carlsen
right now but hopefully you guys enjoyed
this video looking for
word to game eight again magnus carlsen
with a two-point lead in a tournament
thanks for watching